we should be doing a much more nuanced
job rather than just wagging our finger
at everybody and saying everybody should
get the vaccine because vaccine good
at the beginning of this i was waiting
for some sort of guidance about the
vaccine
and people who had already been sick
with covet right because there's an
obvious question here
now let's take the most basic level okay
people who have had
kovid have effectively had a vaccine
to this version of covet right they have
been exposed to those proteins
that's what the immune system is that's
why they got better right the point is
the immune system figured out the plan
the dead ones the ones who died of coba
19 they have not effectively been
vaccinated
they were partially vaccinated but let's
just say if you recover if you actually
had it and you actually recovered the
point is your immune system figured it
out
now do we know that that will have the
same lasting immunity as the vaccine
no but we also don't know that the
vaccine has lasting immunity and there's
every reason to expect it because with
these vaccines so far are doing
is they are exposing the immune system
to the very spike protein
in order that when the virus actually
invades your system your immune system
already knows what it's looking at and
attacks it but here's the thing
so i was waiting for them to say look if
you've had covid
you at least shouldn't get the vaccine
early there are multiple reasons for
this
one is you don't need to take the risk
of the vaccine the vaccine isn't just
the spike protein
right or the mrnas that will create it
it's also the
lipid nanoparticles it's also whatever
medium it's in
it's a lot of things and so why take the
risk if you've effectively had the
vaccine
that's one question and there's another
question which is how do these things
interact now it may be that some
immunologically
very well-educated person will have some
answer to this i don't see coming but
here's the question
your immune system functions on the
basis that
your cells will be able to recognize
and uh attach to the
proteins for which they are uh targeted
right so you
get spike protein into your system your
system figures out the electromagnetic
sequences that result in
antibodies and or t cells being able to
stick to this thing
and that's how it works right now if you
get a vaccine right that generates
spike protein those spike proteins which
are not associated with virus
will stick to those cells and antibodies
that are
targeted at them there comes a point at
which you may saturate those things and
you may in fact open the door to
covid because the point is your immune
system was busy dealing with particles
that weren't associated with virus and
that let virus get through
you know in some other way that is at
least plausible right so
now there has been guidance in the last
week or so
that says if you've had covid you should
get one
of the two vaccinations rather than two
right
so that is at least moving in the
direction of there's a question here but
my point is that question was on the
table from day one and even if nothing
else is true
if it is the case that this vaccine is
as good as we think it is
and as safe as people say it is then the
point is
the people who have had covid would be a
lower priority
because they are already at least
somewhat vaccinated and therefore if the
idea is get the vaccine to as many
people as possible
the policy that says get the vaccine no
matter whether you've had covet or not
is going to kill people because it's
going to leave some people unprotected
so that's a it's again a problem simple
rubrics and that's exactly the third
reason that i was going to put on the
table which you just landed at
which is the third reason not to
prioritize getting the vaccine if you've
had coven 19
is that if we are being told the truth
and i believe we are in this regard
that we don't have enough supply and
that we are trying to distribute
it as the vaccines as effectively and
efficiently as possible to the people
who need it most
then the people who almost certainly
have onboard endogenous
endogenously generated immunity already
should not be first in line
for the vaccine yep there's this if
there's a supply problem the people
who are particularly high risk from the
vaccine
like people with autoimmune diseases or
i think pregnant women and children
probably shouldn't be first in line and
people who are likely already to have
immunity that they themselves generated
should not be first online
yep and i would say we can add another
reason
for uh for skepticism here at least for
the
already exposed or already infected with
covid once
crowd which is the way these vaccines
work the mrna is going to get into cells
it's going to cause the production of
spike proteins which are going to be
displayed by those cells i believe the
fate of those cells will then be that
they will be targeted
by t cells and killed or
they will have apoptosis programs
activated
in other words the body will deal with
them like they're
infected with the virus right so the
point is
you're killing tissue that's not going
to be good for you either
so you know there are let's put it this
way a logical analysis
suggests that there are all sorts of
reasons that we should be doing a much
more nuanced job rather than just
wagging our finger at everybody and
saying everybody should get the vaccine
because vaccine good
[Music]
right
you